even as more and more nevadans get
vaccinated those who are not eligible
yet
feel left in the dark that includes
people with chronic health conditions
orco mana shares their concerns we have
been living in
intense and constant stress 32 year old
las vegas samantha russell has been
diagnosed with cancer
three times the disease combined with
treatment has taken its toll
on her immune system it does make people
like me
anxious the best protection against the
coronavirus
is the vaccine but according to the
state's vaccination playbook russell is
not eligible yet
it is hard to feel like
immunocompromised people or people with
disabilities
people like me are being prioritized
it's frustrating when
there are appointments available and
there are a lot of time slots open
this is a look at available appointments
this week at southern nevada health
district vaccine sites
we have a lot of capacity dr michael
gardner runs the unlv coveted 19 vaccine
clinics and says they're able to
administer
2 000 doses a day but they're not since
fewer people are signing up we're doing
maybe a little bit more than half of
what we could be doing we're afraid
that'll be the case until we get
some expansion of the lanes that were
allowed to vaccinate dr gardner says
he'd like to see nevadans with chronic
conditions added to the mix and russell
hopes that happens soon
just to know that we have that extra
layer of protection
will be the biggest weight lifted off of
our shoulders
orcomanna 8 news now now we reached out
to the state's health response team as
well as a southern nevada health
district to ask
when those with underlying conditions
could expect to become eligible
they have not gotten back to us just yet